you saw it when protesters literally
tried to pry open the 13 ton bronze
doors of the Supreme Court and he saw it
when an Tifa took over Portland
physically attacking cars leftist
violence is also spilling onto college
campuses though impacting our students
the Republicans son of Obama National
Security Advisor Susan Rice says that he
was assaulted at Stanford University at
an event believe it or not supporting
Brett Kavanaugh his best friend who
witnessed it Ben Esposito is joining us
tonight ban it's good to see you is the
treasurer of the of the Stanford College
Republicans been take us through what
happened here yes thank you Laura great
to be here so we have these events
regularly change my mind events where we
promote conservative viewpoints on a
campus that frankly doesn't have a lot
of them so we were standing up today or
the other day for due process and during
this event one of the protesters who
showed up kind of got upset at John and
showed up and and pushed him and you
know hit him and pushed him back and we
eventually had to call the police and
make sure everything got settled down
and it was a woman I understand is that
right yes that's right yeah
male student are you identifying her
you're afraid to identify her who is she
um well we've we've identified her on
our Facebook um I don't think we need to
throw her name out I mean her first name
is Melinda I don't think we need to
throw our name out to the masses but
yeah so she assaulted John and right now
we're pressing charges
John okay so and she was upset because
you were exercising your First Amendment
rights I mean what she's she's a
well-known leftist on campus not not
really this in fact it's kind of crazy
that you know it's actually something we
had no idea cuz you do know some
prominent you know very liberal students
on campus but this is just another
another person yeah so I she was upset
at John was filming her for ripping
these flyers because we're just trying
to get this documented end I know she
wasn't happy at that and she she
attacked him for it is it harder for
Susan Rice's son given her prominence in
the Obama administration for him to be a
Republican does he faced more pushback
just because of his his fan
I think perhaps but really I think the
reason he faces the most pushback I mean
anywhere is because he's he's a
conservative on a college campus
promoting individual liberty I mean
every day you know you it's very
difficult for students event and any
student to promote conservatism its
students are expected to conform hey Ben
keep doing exactly what you're doing
because guess what there are a lot more
students who agree with you and you have
to have fun doing it and you have to
keep doing it okay I went through the
same thing at Dartmouth keep doing what
you're doing we salute you and give our
give our best year pal okay and stay
safe all right we look we will keep
fighting thank you